well I watching your journey and being
such a huge fan of yours and I think
there's also a way to be taught and
educated to open minds and there are
those who can and I think you have that
gift I really do I'm a musical theater
major well and you actually have
oh well get this I I you know activism
scares the heck out of me especially I
think when you come out as trans there's
this automatic like Girl Scout patch
that gets put on you like activist
and I think my way in is through comedy
and yeah I'm doing um my day 365 tonight
is going to be at the rainbow room I'm
doing an old Hollywood style Broadway
show Cabaret and I'm basically at the
legendary rain rainbow room it's going
to be costume changes and um all the
proceeds go to the cover project to
support queer youth wonderful so that'll
be live stream tonight well I can't wait
to watch it and I can't wait to continue
to watch your journey and
um it is such a pleasure to finally make
your acquaintance and I hope that it can
turn into we've got I'm going yeah
I love you so much
um what is one thing that you would like
for people to take away from your
journey as it's ongoing but just for
today I would say
that you know yourself better than
anyone does and
please hold on to your favorite parts of
yourself because I let a lot of my
favorite Parts go as a child and as a
teen and I'm now trying to find them
again I've found a lot of them this past
year and I've shared those things but if
I was able to hold on to those even
earlier I think I mean the possibilities
are Limitless and so try to hold on to
those things because you know yourself
and also I heard a story about a girl
that came up to you and said I am having
a parallel Journey yes and your videos
explaining your Journeys have helped my
family understand I was seeing a
Broadway musical I was in the line for
the women's restroom and the girl behind
me tapped me on the shoulder and says me
and my mom watch your videos every night
together that's like part of their
routine and I was like is your mom here
and we walked upstairs and her mom
started crying and I I think that trans
and queer youth are some of the
strongest human is alive the fact that
they are pushing through to be
themselves but I think the parents are
just as important so I got to thank that
Mom just for for supporting their child
and loving their child and isn't that
like a I'm not a parent but isn't that
like a parent's greatest hope I think as
a parent that story spoke to me because
we don't know what to do all the time we
have instincts we develop things we grow
and learn but the more you know we can
be given the tools and taught and
storytelling the better parents will be
so thank you for being that Beacon for
that family
[Applause]
and for tickets and more info visit 365
days of
girls.com we'll be right back
[Music]